I'm over here Jackson Oconee this good
there's a there's a drought dude in the
well what what do you do oh my god he
spawned there he can be our drowned boy
Oh little drowning boy paid by the way
do you remember last episode where we
put a lot baby llama I come and said
that once he grows up he's gonna choke
oh why don't we that they're two blocks
tall right they're too much oh here you
want seed yeah Herot we want dirt live
on buddy
Wow clearly one of us values I'm higher
than the other hey you can have an egg
baby you made a baby chicken get it yeah
it's our chat no no difference is there
any way to make them be tiny forever
because that would be so cute just don't
feed them yes they cute forever stay
cute in your prison forever check
another thing I think dang morning honey
okay another thing a common set is if
you put hay underneath I literally just
said that before
oh sorry do you want to do it no did you
prepare it before the episode do you
have it in your hand I don't I don't
have enough for a bit okay whatever
whatever okay oh did you give it to me
okay wait no you need you need to go up
top to see the smoke rice oh my gosh
wait creeper creeper baby oh man oh hey
hey bro gotta come you look down I'm
just munching on hay like a horse oh
yeah where the hay go hello hey Doc hey
Oh God I'm watching oh wait we have the
hole okay do it do it do bruh dude wait
the creepers on me bro
hey what am i here down there I'm
killing the creeper stop stop okay he
did he did okay okay are you ready I'm
friggin ready bro ready for epic gaming
tips we do work out is it really cool
are you not saying anything because of
how it goes hi is it is it cool yeah it
is cool
it's good I need to make soft potatoes
what is that a big ship super cheap
super soap they're speaking the language
of the gods
whoa it is really high told you bruh
told you do you think from space this
either looks cool or like a giant bomb
man
haha don't ever disrespect a pyramid
upside down sorry
I eat potato do you have more potato
because I'm hungry I have I have
uncooked potatoes I'll take on to the
forge to the Forge how we're still so
bad in this server it's like the only
thing we've done is build a nonsense
and that's it only because we could not
because we should are you cooking
potatoes bread yeah Irish I always got
him on me you realize that we made the
Minecraft equivalent of big brain this
is big brain building I'm physical
manifested that was a word but I know
how to don't mind if I steal a baked
potato is a pretty good you didn't ever
baked potatoes in your game no I know
some sort of meat eater I'm not Irish
sorry that's ok we should we should
actually plant more potatoes in yeah ok
great
yeah we need to start at the fruiting
situation I feel like they have a little
farm setup I'm kind of just using those
yeah take that take that
and then we're let's put patek potatoes
potatoes you know all about dough's
don't you put some splits down oh no
your whole rope yeah notes my ho-ho I
was gonna make it your mom joke but now
I've met your mom and it's uncomfortable
thank you rob she was lovely as she
praised my dance move she praised her
dance moves
yeah she didn't praise my dance moves as
she said for fun with me luck
the bear was like school for fun that's
funny
school of a 5 what did she say all the
fun she just said fafa
no or you speak the language of the
cards
this is our little train train train
choo-choo choo-choo
5250 chop chop choo-choo do you think we
can get a petition to change the name of
the game to Minecraft
why some umlauts above it for swedish my
shop Oh mine shop
a lot of stuff in this one why is this
one all the way over here um I don't we
we have three diamond 36 iron
oh my diamond pickaxe oh yeah [ __ ]
crooks you didn't know you had it no I
forgot I the only things that never tie
in minecraft
I'm an Sam and my time Ithaca well okay
I have a confession to make which is I I
swapped our pickaxes so here you go
I feel bad you know what I can't do it
you know what you you were honest
okay friendship oh I'm also gonna put
away my diamond pickaxe cuz I'm
absolutely gonna die now you can live
forever in a simulation yeah I was just
thinking what was I doing
uh the formics it I need to make a hole
make a hole huh
make up huh what Oh Oh the guys are
joining in oh whoa huh I think someone
is making her as a mixer pack now as
well you have like ten emeralds you can
get a sharpness - iron sword we have
four oh dang it
um are we saying texture pack uh I think
someone's making a texture pack of us so
eventually we'll look pretty cool oh I
heard steel maruzen it's almost like
love is everywhere and we are not
organized it wait there it is wow that's
crazy and now that part is gonna be
there forever brain that is a big brain
big brain how do I make a hole just use
the little book I'm trying to be big no
that's for small brains I would never
I'm small brain my series is epic
Oh as I place the trap door under me
instead of a block here right Wow you
throw it like small brain baby I don't
like throwing my ho too hard
that's Wow I'm gentle with my ho there
you go now we both have hush Oh big
think Oh large welcome enormous
acknowledgement where we build the
friend
we've water around here we have water
down here so maybe we should do they
what they're sheep with the Sheep
we will never forget you except that we
did everyone was mad at us for leaving
everything back there well get back to
it one day it would be like in part
hungry because I died and came all the
way back for a gray people don't realize
you please so much minecraft that we
just want to play Minecraft that's the
thing isn't it so in a lady that you
just want to blame a crazy lady get mad
baby you had a little bit no I'm gonna
demand a millet yeah yep sure hmm this
really is an old school let's play out
how many blocks away can we do for the
water still be effective I think too but
I'm not sure mm-hmm
what are you planting wheat or we
appetizer I have wheat I have wheat and
I have pumpkin there uses pumpkins I'm
bet you can tray them they're like the
moneymaker this is so cozy
just a couple boys like farming in a
night what did you plan melons yeah
that's the only thing I have now on but
you said it was useless so now I feel
like pumpkins are useless melons are
great
oh I planted pumpkin I said it wrong oh
oh my god so many children
somebody children their attack whoa what
the children raids there's three
children kill the children their
nine-year-old
I mean kick them don't you can't say
kill make them faint
it's okay bro I got you I back you up
thanks man
level 10 hey you've seen what happens
when you plant for treason or oh right
yeah I just did that in my episodes okay
I'm doing it here epidote tree house for
the boys only boys though only bullets
nudie mags in it
did you do that no no it's kind of the
thing that everyone said they did but no
one actually did I did Jesus oh man
indeed we should change it to creeper oh
yeah maybe then it'll be nice dude that
is one of those big brain thing I have
ever heard maybe they just want a friend
like no hug me today my brothers where's
your gold and shoot they're unloaded
chest alright so we could keep building
the pyramid I have a lot of cobblestone
oh my god wait alright damn it
got him you didn't get anything all you
got was a knuckle sandwich oh you're
gonna put my lights out put your lights
to the max I'm drinking a few Oh G fuel
epic tweeting epic sour cherry he's
drinking the language of the car are we
just building this bigger again yes
Dini come soon I got Japan I have 12 so
yes II go bruh uh there's a flower biome
nearby oh that we should I feel like we
should go why are you obsessed with
flower biomes they're rare I'm like
three of mine okay alright
it's the one that can find a desert
after 20 parts shut up I found it over
me I felt a flag I think we have a leash
so we could take the team of fox for the
boys I mean we don't really need to tame
him we just need to steal him and put a
name tag on him mm-hmm spider stay away
from crop what says stay away spider
song and in Ireland do you guys have a
stay-away spider song am serving suspend
that that hoody blue
mudal fluid l plural shop shop shop shop
shop
[Laughter]
Wow should we put our stuff in the
pyramid so it has some usage it's we're
building to Jesus okay we're gonna we're
gonna focus the moon beam down into the
porthole yes once the stars are aligned
oh yeah and then it's like Bing bong
Bing bong oh no oh no don't do it with
the book okay and then we have to do
that someone has to jump down we have to
sacrifice a villager oh I like that plan
we get somebody up here may also need it
was goats for a sacrifice yeah come on
minecraft you had a beast let's get some
goats
so altar minecraft we can get what a
sheep that's need been through enough
yes true we need something else oh maybe
maybe our war well guy our son
yeah if he's not dead already we need a
better way to get in the pyramid I think
we can both agree on that right that is
true you built a a piston elevator I'm
not doing that again right now we can't
build water ones cuz we don't have soul
sand alright we don't so saying um maybe
build the dead weight we had nether and
now we're not there anymore I think we
have some obsidian
okay zombie should we sleep yeah let's
sleep sleep good night gamer good night
morning gamers morning papers when you
realize that good morning gamers is a
discount top of the mornin to you ladies
Oh mind equals blown mind equals big God
my inventory is always so messy this is
Bill again no organizational did the
potato grow yet yeah exactly
I need potatoes let's check potatoes
okay yeah I got a bone meat bone meat
sing the potato grow some Shayna feed
for coffee
chop chop
I jumped up Wow
it work that guy died cuz he was so
impressed potato is strong he was like
man God my god good minecraft a
sacrifice was necessary at to cook at
the job I need a piston what do you need
- oh we don't we don't have redstone do
we should we take down two redstone then
yeah I'm gonna get more coal for this
call here as well bang mom sing the coal
sound well are we on 54 mm-hm
yeah but we're working together as a
team
don't walk past diamonds again just
pretend it was one time dude
and you know what it was worth it cuz
those diamonds lasted me forever
yeah I'm still having it yeah but
becomes Shawn just like it's so
beautiful another one for the High Line
ah another one for my demo reel you know
when you just get too mad lads together
the jokes does never stop it just never
stops the whole thing becomes a montage
so fluent you're diggin on two separate
floors with me and it's bothering me all
right my fault that you're slow stairs
are one of them okay I was thinking the
same that's perfect we are so in sync
Oh down here and our moon oh yeah Oh
clear air hey careful careful give me I
find the love oh oh don't forget to eat
potatoes that could have been the death
of me wait where do we fold them from
I'm trying to make sure we find our way
back
so we don't have to dig a hole for the
400 tire heads did you get the little
sticky 60 I got a little sniffle sniffle
cold
I think old so many jolt can I get rid
of scent I don't like should I kill an
Enderman no yeah it's gang up on him
where is he
hey Amy this way we should roast him
first
lower his courage his charisma stat yeah
- vile eh
amen more like Slenderman a anther man
more like Long Legs man we're gonna
teleport to you mama
teleport then where you cry tell it for
your tears I was awful I feel terrible
yeah I never want to do that again here
sir mr. Steadman whatever we are now 19
okay
getting close gamers soon we will have
stones that are wait oh my god damn this
guy's rich there's like three more here
oh yes
whoa there's so many yeah I need to eat
are they're shooting each other
you have potato yeah you need food yeah
health right here good oh they are
crystal I think yeah yeah here's your
steaks I throw them down oh no wrong
with you die man did you find it die man
let me block off what don't let the
money get to your head jack the water
make me is it'll actually just one is
lit I've never seen this little diamond
in my life what's the Fricker Frank
that's Africa game or a moment okay you
get the diamond I have no room for it
I'll get red stone I don't think I've
room
okay.i room for one cool we got one
diamond Jay okay we should probably get
the obsidian actually while we're at it
okay you get that I don't have a diamond
pickaxe at me ah leave me hangin bro
yeah cuz I'm gonna die and lose it you
know me I can't be trusted
you managed to keep it safe so far
jacket don't sell yourself short
no I know my worth now trash I'm garbage
okay so we need 10 right yeah okay okay
I might need to get out of here cuz
three Hertz no food way a food Hey I II
mommy mommy ie
Oh to talk terse and tack but today I'm
late
Marta's doing the Swedish duolingo now
really it's even the duolingo sounds
crap
I'm like no Manon but these days it's
like this yeah actually it sounds like
how well that's how they sound like -
okay do we have flint and steel I feel
like we had one I don't think we haven't
with us gamer oh that's not forgets
golden you get two golden I don't get :
that sounds bad
minecraft memoirs mine Mars all right I
think we can go up now damn there's so
much here let me see if there's oh god
don't get greedy
yeah are you here oh god I'm safe so we
came in I remembered to block this time
I keep forgetting that I can block
creepers over the shield should you yeah
make know me she'll break I'm right
above you okay yeah don't jump that I'm
gonna go up with the water just want to
see if their assignments here or there I
don't see any usually in the hallways is
good wait is it just like snoopin you
know like look at these stairs who built
these this is not the stairs of gamers
the stairs of lamerz oh you mean he make
their way up yeah should that make
stairs
yeah mixer right now yeah brawny stairs
right now right now oh I know I know my
head by head by brain you never made
stairs by brain bruh old family
tradition do it every Sunday
oh the shell Berg's are excellent stair
makers this is what we do years for
years
daddy shell Berg would come home and say
where's my stairs where's my where's my
snooze exactly how he sounded its taste
and oconee this gun back yeah
come up to me son disappointed son Goku
nadeska I don't what's terraces and
Japanese and it's hard to my dated
steady
yeah probably we had to obsidian yeah
that's why I got apron what do you think
I am pointed out and any more redundant
facts you want to give me the floor is
made of floor I realized the way the
stairs are now you still have to dig one
up because that's all you do I have
bones I do I thought we were onto
something but okay so why do you watch
Jack inspire me cuz if they can do it
anyways like become youtubers like you
know that's stupid crap you say all the
time
yeah just record yourself two minutes
sleep good morning gamers what do we
need what's our goal well we can
probably we should build a nether portal
somewhere do you have that too what
about Oh creepy creeper creeper Jessica
can I build a piston why not what am I
missing
that rhymed look if we did that one man
here Thursday obsidian okay epic thank
you if do you want a void brain idea can
you wait two seconds come out keep just
come here jump in this compost yeah this
is the this yeah you can't go in there
it's a little tricky day again nicely
okay do you trust me yeah okay stay
there turn in now this is a little cheap
Oh
trust me jack just me I trust you it's
for the pyramid what we need gracious
sacrifice it does not work ok George oh
you have to sing song cheap show cheap
[ __ ] up shop I am going to ship so cheap
oh right right before the potatoes wait
where'd he go what happened what did you
get my redstone torch it's fine I'll
make another yeah here no I make it
there we go oh can you see oh yeah
there's a spider right below me what
else can your elephant ice I mean Irish
I see uh coal lava creeper two spiders
can you see the future Jack I can see
something
did I take potato drug this is the ice
of water sheep oh I didn't know you
could do this this is the sheet
sheathing I never did it though okay let
me let me see the future okay you going
it's not [ __ ] if in-game everyone knows
everyone knows it just exploit okay
breath do you mean it right I want to
see the future what ah
so these are see two spiders below you
oh my god that's do spiders below me
bruh they're like two hands in the night
oh hey I don't see the spiders Oh Frick
er ah Frank is cheating don't like it
Jack stop making machine I'm not making
you cheat
okay the other thing was the nether
portal but you show me what you wanted
to do do you want to do big brain nether
portal in the pyramid what if reverse
pyramid turns into real pyramid on top
so it looks like a d20 die from so
nether portals in the middle like a
summoning chamber ooh okay we have oh
that's tricky to build though but I
think it's possible
mmm it's gotta be off center though
I hate things that are off-center oh
wait we can be little larger fault
Don Genie two or four and we have three
what do you mean what if he how many
bucks you need to invite him to make it
bigger you just build it any size yeah
what so we just need more obsidian what
if we just break off a side of this and
then you can open up this and the
smokers in front of it making it
mysterious I like mysteries hey I love
Scooby Doo I do actually love Scooby Doo
all right so one two like that please
send well yeah
well it's either three or five two can't
like fill out the rest of it but let's
start I've never built any one that's
bigger than the regular one
I don't have the mats for that right now
so you just build whatever you need to
so we need oh did I do wrong
yeah no it's three on bottom three on
top okay there we go that's wait you had
it right
Oh dummy dumb all it took was two
seconds for your big eyes to catch up
with your big brain hey I remember syrup
sandwiches and crema Louis hey wait hey
okay okay I'm gonna go through just to
check what's happening like yeah what if
you come through it there's just lava oh
this is our first portal oh really
yeah they're connected that means we can
go home to homeland hello hello this is
epic then the smoke signals
kind of like blocking never I was like
oh is that a nether portal or someone
just vaping over there dude no man okay
well no
what did you do
it connected back to another plan oh no
I was literally about to come through to
see what you were doing
stop stop you come all the way back here
now I'm in the underwater wine oh no
wait we're keep coming back through them
and then it might fart you out here no I
don't think so
what's your coordinates - 700 - mm
should I bring some soulsand or you're
the new show the new Sean well at least
we can make I get some soul sing we need
it okay bring the count yeah magma
blocks no that sucks you song sin lifts
you and I have like a lot of food
prepared as well so like you're gonna
make it bro I'm gonna make it not gonna
break it okay oh I remember syrup
sandwiches sandwiches are literally
probably for the better
yeah yeah there we go safer is better
sandwiches I got a bunch of bum bark
with syrup sandwiches chip-chop cheap
top ten with is there is there Swedish
rap songs no it doesn't exist it's also
probably for the better
boom fala Lala fala Lala fala choking a
Swedish chicken here do you remember the
movie written by Hank green what is it
called Faulkner stars yes and the guy in
like Swedish hop sorry sorry John to
remember and then he sinks the guy that
looks evil and place it Green Goblin
spider-man James Franco No Green Goblin
first the original he's dead oh well I'm
default Willem Dafoe in that movie likes
Swedish hip-hop and he plays this
cringes hip hop song ever boom father
died left for a little look it's really
funny I was the only one laughing in the
cinema we have a lead back here you want
me to tell more stories that are only
funny to me I got plenty
[Laughter]
dude I'm busy playing Minecraft no I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah find that
song afterwards because I want to hear
it I couldn't find my way back to the
port so I'm just gonna walk back but
I'll bring a souvenir
I'll bring some in there oh special
little flower yeah yeah yeah of course
marzia working my phone special little
flower what was the other coordinate -
700 - 700 - 2000 bro that's far away Oh
huh I am very
potat oh and it's getting very late and
I don't have personally getting very
late give my boy potat huh I'm lying in
bed dreaming of you do you I don't know
to be seen do you ever know that your
potato the way to your dreams I need a
lead cuz I want to get a fox we have to
bro where then we kill the traitor
somewhere no without no no sorry that
was my sister slaves oh you know what I
let it slide just for this week only
though cuz it's special it special we
thank you
I did see that Marcia wanted to call the
place potato though so oh you picked a
good one so you know I knew after all
these times of hanging out and all these
years of friendship that was the moment
I know it's the moment and I'm burning
this fire just so I know which way I've
been I mean I'm burning this forest that
I say I'm burning this fire you're
you're the problem with the environment
big bright no no don't burn forest just
like don't throw your car batteries in
the ocean that's all I ask people
actually do that how do Ballas do you
get rid of them another way but not the
ocean oh I'm sorry
so you get rid of your counter batteries
oh I'm sorry am i killing the
environment Oh am i sorry my declining
Oh manatee oh it's the burger Lucroy
buddy
oh if environment is real then why can't
I see it
why is there not an environment - oh my
god minecraft so real they made it in
real life
what there's swamp in real life I don't
know what I'm doing I'm basically just
running back and
this is because I don't play I just chat
I've no goal stop talking objecting it's
too bit under drain slime kill kill oh
yeah we can make leads Oh excellent I
killed it but I think I might die on the
way okay my coordinates are - 700 - 1005
minute oh I made it I'm gonna oh you're
so good I'm gonna kill some cows for
science am I really
yeah - 1500 yeah you need to get to
minus 19 or mm okay I'm not coming that
way I'm a rider rider a knight oh
there's tons of fishes hey I can just
chopped up them you're gonna make some
sushi bro I'll make some sushi
you want some salmon oh I can't cook
them I don't have a cobblestone can ate
them raw will I die ya know like just
like in real life
minecraft is just like reality they knew
what they were doing Cole died - no Sh
I wanna cook stuff but our base is
surrounded by bad boys cannot sleep I
cannot dream tonight my indecision to
call you as that Coldplay
please some of your yoking is that David
Bowie will have Halloween on Christmas
leave me not play one blink song on the
wedding either play blink or good
Charlotte okay
did you I don't know I was too busy
tearing it up tearing it up oh did I get
a slice I do remember doing a spin
between your legs
very great do the dance more together I
did it
know is epic you slid under me and then
we did break dancing together oh I got
the slime okay nice oh I feel bad
killing this line white because they're
really cute and they don't hurt you when
they're tiny but he killed your dad no
that's spider-man got it that's why they
took him out of the Marvel Universe
yeah what happened with that it's only
Owens spider-man and they were like
lending it to Marvel yeah for the movies
but Marvel make like no money off it's
like a 95 5 split in Sony's favor for
the mob no way so all of the merch I
think goes to Marvel
and they're like no we want 5050 and
Sony we're like hell no damn companies
being greedy companies doing business
however you only notice right now that
we have two chests next to each other
that are small instead of one large
chest yeah it's big brain is it because
at the workbench sometimes you play some
it just happens
hey I'm half a heart I have half a heart
knows the words not ever
oh god there's zombies wait where are
you there's Foxy's you having fun no I'm
scared okay well I if I knew where you
were I could come help I have a chicken
I'm trying to get to 2,000 and 1,900
oh you're super close I know funny I
finally I find out funny funny funny
funny thing with my spiders there's so
many spiders there's a zombie at the
door I don't want to know about your
Lord and Savior
sleep sleep you sleep sleep sleep
oh there's too close I can't sleep ah ah
they're over running the house sleep
morning it's almost morning sleep they
okay maybe now I can sleep I can't
there's an Enderman next to me I find a
different house run away Enderman no
stop stop oh I see oh god where are you
I'm at that building where you took away
the wall and there's a workbench so
right next to the pyramid
oh this monster nearby how there's
Enderman oh this morning
you made a chicken she again she kills
you we should kill the spiders and get
their strings because then we can make
leash oh not today spider not today Oh
your organizer inventory epic is that
zombie above or below
is he in great tower is he a big great
big brain pyramid ah he better not there
on my watch because if he is I am going
to be very angry nobody is in big brain
tower I have one leash for each which
rhymes coming Oh chop now we go get
forever Fox
epic and an episode after because it's
highlight video and guys I'm I saw Fox's
back where you came from
yeah yeah same folks folks folks I'm
gonna name mine Felix
Oh Felix the folks I'm gonna make named
mind Sean Michael orange it's not my
name oh no no it's different different
name different name different person
different villagers do you see them know
they've enter in our land we shouldn't
Rihanna be definitely should not because
then we'll our town will get raided oh
yeah but we need to defend our freedom
on there what if we'd all go use ebooks
where did you see Fox Fox where do you
go but I'm over to the right I'm at 7 6
9 1871
I see Fox but I can't get close enough
does it have a baby no yeah that's the
one
- I just want to grab him and then we
can have him Oh for good luck and
fortune fortune favors the bold but I
can't I can't sprint after him yeah he
has a chicken in his mouth come welcome
come I come I come I come I come I come
II got him yep your attache pull pull
pull
wait boom boom I mixed ears we name him
blip blop blip blop I don't know that's
a hard one to put in the birth
certificate what do you want to be
called
look at the pyramid from here oh that's
awesome
wait I only have some of it loaded in
doesn't change for me
blip blop blip blop come on little folks
blip blop little [ __ ] what what is it
name aren't Slipslop Slipslop what if
you do huh she is the Fox book
what is it name-o
[Laughter]
do you still have him no I lost my leash
somewhere people are people I got him
now I got him - blip blop blip I can't
let's pull him in two different
directions bring bleep blop back to base
and I bring I bring back flip-flop shame
shame on you flip-flop I named him
flip-flop but now he dead so maybe I
shouldn't have named him before I
killing him it's okay plan yeah thank
God he loved he loved he gave her love
he's super like I realize you can't give
very well you have lead yeah it's okay
is it make sure you doing in there don't
let him out no bleep love will eat them
he cannot eat what I kill hmm you use
big ring tongue he's using the language
of the big break
I have to make a fence and I don't have
it would I like that while we're
building the pyramid we're also building
to this building next good it's like a
crazy straw the irony of laughs we put
bleep up here
[Music]
blip blop Oh parks and he is really cool
if you don't think about it then you
gonna have to go up big Plaza we said
that brizzy's a rapper Fox Plus you know
sick beats good bluff who's your
favorite dad it's me oh man one day it's
much like subscribe yeah if you like
folks then hit like birthday well you
haven't tried to pursue me later today
after 50 million our troops down just
now it's still relevant
just down